we're going to turn now to stand-up
comedian love her too zarna Garg is her
name she's here in studio Garg was a
stay-at-home mom for 16 years before she
tried her first open mic job in her 40s
it wasn't long before she gained fans at
comedy clubs and on social media she has
more than listens 15 million likes on
her Tick Tock account alone her first
stand-up special on Prime video is
called one in a billion and this is a
clip
there's some things I'll just never get
used to in this country like here people
love to say I love you all the time and
to everybody
like I love you in the morning I love
you in the evening going to school I
love you came home from work I love you
empty the dishwasher
really love you
so much love
I hate it
I've never said I love you to my husband
says I love you to you you know he's
cheating
but don't but isn't that smart yes yeah
yeah because where is he learning it
Donna gargas you see is here at the
table and I guess we can thank your
children for this turn in your life well
I mean thank them or or blame them or
blame them but your kids encourage you
Mom you should try stand-up comedy did
you think you were funny no never I'm
don't really like I mostly just go out
there and like rant and yell at my kids
and their friends and who are like if
I'm at Dwayne Reed and I see the
checkout I'm like please take the mcats
please why aren't you you know take the
CPA exam on Saturday like you know I
don't know I can't stop myself but they
encourage you though they said you
should because did you want a job you
said you had been home for 16 years were
you looking for a job yes I really
wanted to get back into the workforce
you have 16 years of being home strips
you of your self-confidence but I wanted
a job job that came with money and
income and my kids are like do stand-up
comedy I'm like that's not a job yeah
yeah yeah in the stand up you have great
stage presence you know how to be a
stand-up you own the space you have you
pause where and you let the Applause
land you have the laughs land like all
that is a talent and a skill yeah how
did you go from never done it before to
that good question so in the Indian
Community comedy is not a thing we don't
believe in fun
no it's a thing like we are stressed out
people and we prefer it that way we're
preparing for the Apocalypse at all
times so even though I was funny I was
the inappropriate one my whole life I
always saw things differently yes but
people would give me the market events
like you say something knowing that
they'll say something probably wrong I
probably get trolled for it later but
make people laugh then and you know I've
been doing that my whole life and I
guess this became a bigger version of it
yeah so one of the things that you do in
your comedy you don't hold back on
anybody in your life from your husband
to your kids to your mother-in-law to
your community your community as a first
generation American I'm like scared for
you because I know the one thing we
generally when you're you have family
not born in this country is don't
embarrass us in front of these Americans
and out there every day you're doing
that yeah it's too late that's just
I'm a New Yorker I'm part of the comedy
community I love this world now that I'm
discovered it yeah and why aren't we a
part of it I'm like what this has been
going on the first open mic I did I was
like people do this this is like you
know and get paid but but there were a
couple times I thought oh how is this
going to play you talk about spelling
bees yes and you said it not me yeah you
said that six of the last eight winners
of spelling bees have been Indian and
the community was upset devastated they
were devastated because it wasn't eight
out of eight because you said that
translates to a c and that's a
chiropractor and that's not a real
doctor you said yeah but but
when you look
in the in the spelling bee many of the
winners are Indian yes why do you think
that is because we're not good at other
things what do you mean what does that
mean we do not add
really singers we don't know how don't
get us to dance like please are you
kidding I've seen
you just hop it's like light up at night
not high hopping like like just a little
you know so it's good they're good at
spelling and it's like you know people
think Asian parenting like Tiger but
we're not that because we're like sit in
one room and read the book that's the
most parenting we can do we also have so
many kids how many events are you gonna
go to you know spellings easier good at
spelling but bad at spelling with your
name what's the story behind it yeah my
name is misspelled it's actually a
misspelling it's true
which means waterfall in Hindi but I was
the youngest of four so I think my
parents were like let the servants name
her it's fine and the servants were like
we've never used the Z nobody seems to
use it so like give it to her I saw
USANA we were on the train Eureka was on
the train yeah we were all there in
different places and you were heading to
Washington because you were opening up
for Amy Amy Faye Tina Fey and Amy
Poehler yes so how did that go you were
on the road with them I mean like you
know this isn't only in America
situation this would not happen back
home even for me is only in America that
you can do work and somebody like Tina
Fey and Amy bowler maybe like we like it
so much you should be a part of our team
and you know when you get that call
you're like wait I can tell your people
how horrible my mother
yes let's go but zarno you said that you
know you would say that um you believe
that Destiny brought you there for a
reason that you're on a train with Amy
Poehler and Tina Fey Gail King darika
not get all these people and you said
that brown women deserve to laugh yes
yes because in our culture we are we
don't believe it or not I'm a clean
comic in America right but in India and
in a lot of brown Nations women hide and
watch my videos they're not even allowed
to watch what I do like because making
fun of your mother-in-law making even
mentioning your religion making fun of
your husband no you said your husband's
superpower is logic it's like being
married
who doesn't become so Superman logic is
like you know something falls on my head
he's like you put too much stuff on it
that's helpful if you know what I mean
so but in our culture we don't do that
it's not encouraged and like in this
whole world I'm the only one doing
something I thought when I came out from
under the stay-at-home mom thing I was
like I'm sure there's thousands of
people doing this because you feel like
everything's being done and then I
looked around like no one's doing it no
one wants it what and the world's
biggest super villain the Indian
mother-in-law
no your first show you they said just
get five people in and 90 people showed
up yeah
no people are very your family first
time I'm proud of you too yeah
unbelievable your husband's okay your
kids are okay they're proud of you true
okay okay
we take what we can get okay Zara we are
cheering you on I can't wait
congratulations where you go from here
you can watch one in a billion it is
hilarious I had to run to the bathroom a
couple times right now in Prime video I
was laughing so hard